This parabola will open down and it has a vertex at negative 1,3. Excellent
work if you got this vertex correct. In order to find this vertex, we need to
complete the square for these x terms. This x squared term has a coefficient of
negative 2, so I'm going to factor that out from these two terms first in order
to complete the square. So we'll have 2 two, times x squared, plus 2x, plus
some unknown number. Now, this number is the number we'll use to complete the
square. And the positive 1 will just stay outside on the end. The b value is
positive 2. So, we know b divided 2 equals 1. And b divided by 2 squared equals
1 as well. This means that we'll need to add one in order to complete the
square for these terms. But we really didn't just add one here, we really added
1 times negative 2, or a total of negative 2. Let's think about this in iterms
of distribution. We have negative 2x squared, we have negative 4x and we have
negative 2. Because we subtracted two from this equation, we really need to add
2 to make sure that it's balanced. We really add 0. This is why we have to put
a positive 2 on the end of our equation here. Now, we're ready to rewrite this
as a perfect square. That perfect square is x plus 1. We'll still have negative
2 out in front, and we'll have positive 1 and positive 2 added on the end. This
gives us our equation in vertex form, so we can easily identify the vertex. We
set the binomial equal to 0, to get an x value of negative 1. And the k, or the
y coordinate of the vertex, is just 3. This is how we get the vertex of
negative 1,3. It's right here. Now, to get the other points, let's use this a
value of negative 2. I can zoom in one my vertex, and then we can see we move
one to the left and one to the right, and two units down to get these other two
points on our parabola. Since this parabola is y equals, we know we need to
move negative 2 down from the vertex once we move 1 left and one right. This
gives us our points of negative 2, 1 and 0,1. Notice how the y coordinate here
and here are two less than the y coordinate of the vertex here. This is why the
a value is so important when it comes to graphing parabolas, and makes our
graphing much more simple.